зігмар у габріелю 57
провини віце-канцлер це ось ніч з міністр
економіки таймер і таки не міченим а так
вже лідер соціал-демократів та партнер
ангели меркель
ви широкий виродками коаліції у team
виступати і суперником на посаду
канцлера габріель на різак але на тому
місці затисненого беня ти посаду міністра
за кордон справними чинами за місцем
франко вольтера штайнмайєром над чи
brexit прямий і трампа рясні сфери
це конфлікту в Україні піших ніж червоний
ви ікл в українському уп це не самий
учням за ними чини один із головних
арбітрів лише сторонами конфлікту на
донбасі вінду опікуються в занурення
мінська я ксардаса зігмар габріель у
такого баот аналітики називайте нато
лояльним до кремля
ранку поза муну лавру кабіна з
причин і в ній на думку ведмедик і вам
і берліном заявив проникнися
кракову висловлювання сантей з проти
росії
названа чомусь ще його партія Петра і
мало їх не проводжають габріелі за ігор
слів і виступаючи за справу з москвою
поважає себе у відривала ізоляція
нічого набрид з діалог політик на
окуджаве давидовичу та москву повстанню
Варіс йому на лузі руку над бомбарда
волю росію сирійського алеппо
то де габріак і суму в усі завжди в
виду і було каміну cool і вино самі
заходу за росію до стрільців у першій
зігмар габріель був москві 80-м apple і
захід би кутова в олімпійські ігри